there's actually a person and we've had
Paul Lucas on before uni watch columnist
for Sports Illustrated founder of uni
watch calm so he's the Guru when it
comes to uniforms new uniforms those who
should get new uniforms and he's very
maniacal about this and we appreciate
his passion Paul joins us now does the
does did Cleveland have to get approval
to use the color rush jerseys more often
this season yes then they did because
normally whether you have a throwback or
an alternate or your color rush whatever
your non primary uniform is you're
normally only allowed to wear that three
times per season but the Browns wanted
to switch from their their current
primary their official primary the one
that has Cleveland in big letters across
the chest and looks kind of more like a
high school jersey they wanted to switch
from that to the the color rush and so
they petitioned the league for that and
the league said yes and so now this is
their new primary brown uniform and I
have to say if you think there's may be
such a thing as too much Brown this
might be it because you've got the brown
jersey with with the brown pants and it
remains to be seen if they're also going
to wear it with the brown socks but the
I know it was named after Paul Brown and
like you said when we think of the
brands we think of brown but man that's
a lot of brown but you also do you look
at these uniforms and you know there's
certain teams that just don't change
their look like Dallas doesn't change
its look I mean you sometimes have those
throw backs but you know Cleveland this
isn't a throwback uniform that they're
doing is it that the good teams the
established teams don't change their
their look they continue to keep what
it's like Penn State in football right
right right
certainly teams with a deeper heritage
and a longer history don't have to sort
of put a shiny object out there to get
people's attention and they would
probably be a revolt if they did you
know if you're the Green Bay Packers and
and you start monkeying around with
different color combinations and
things like that your fan base is not
going to appreciate that but if you're a
newer team if you're the Jacksonville
Jaguars and you don't have decades and
generations worth of history and
heritage to draw upon you know it may
make more sense or at least you may
think you need to do things to keep
people's attention and to get some some
media attention and to keep those jersey
sales going so it really varies I like
to think of it as Coke versus Pepsi some
teams are more like coke they never
change you know what the coke script
never changes they keep a slogan like
you know enjoy Coca Cola or coke is it
very simple just the fact and then there
are teams that are more like Pepsi which
is constantly changing its logo and has
slogans like the choice of a new
generation or Generation Next very
useful oriented and so some teams or
coke teams and some teams or Pepsi teams
the team or teams that need to change
their uniform in the NFL yeah I would
say the Buccaneers definitely they've
got those digital alarm clock numbers
you know that number font that nobody
likes the Cardinals who are really a
mess right now you know they've got
they've got a helmet with that
old-school gray facemask and that sort
of soldered on to a uniform chassis it's
very newfangled and not old-school at
all it has those like ridiculous striped
sleeves and that ridiculous piping down
the sides of the pan so it's really a
mess I would say the Cardinals might be
number one in terms of needing an
overhaul when do we start seeing ads on
uniforms in the NFL I hope never you
know I'm really hoping that we you know
that that doesn't come around the league
hasn't really flirted any trial balloons
about that yet when the end when the NBA
did it
we heard League executives like Adam
Silver who at that time was not yet
league commissioner he was I think the
number two God David Stern he was
talking about this and saying it would
be inevitable long before it actually
happened that hasn't happened yet in the
NFL you don't hear Roger Goodell or any
of his lieutenants really talking about
oh we're you know we're looking into
that or we never say never or we're kind
of trying to soften up the fan base for
the inevitability of it
it may happen but the wheels don't seem
to be turning on that just yet best
uniforms in all the sports in all sports
I would say the st. Louis Cardinals
baseball the Packers who I mentioned
earlier my big fan of green and gold is
a color combination those are the unis
watch colors so I like the Packers to
New York Rangers in NHL with a white
uniform which is now the I always think
of it as a home uniform that it's now
the road but I remember when the NHL
wore white at home and I love I love
everything that Golden State does in the
NBA their uniform program is awesome
you know what Oregon cultivated here
with all their uniform changes when it
was that two decades ago is it they the
standard-bearer when it comes to this in
terms of changing you know normally as a
team or any kind of brand right you want
to stand for something and what Oregon
decided they were going to stand for was
not standing really for anything or
standing for constant change and it
worked well for them in terms of not
just getting attention but it helped
with their recruiting and they were
successful on the field right like they
they actually improved their program but
when you think about the next team that
tried to do that the University of
Maryland and Under Armour tried to do to
them what Nike had done to Oregon with
you know the flag based uniforms and all
the different changes and it didn't
really work out so well on the field
right and and I think the lesson that
teams have learned from that is that if
you dress like a clown and you win you
look like a winner but if you dress like
a clown and you lose you just look like
a clown and I think if you're going to
be outrageous you better produce on the
field because otherwise you just look
ridiculous but Notre Dame has changed
their uniforms and that's their one of
the standard bearers you know I don't
see USC doing this you know there's
certain Oh Ohio State has changed a
little bit so you what Notre Dame has
done with their shamrock series right
where they play the the one game per
season or it was every season that now
they're taking a break from it where
they would designate one game
for you know per year where they could
sort of go a little nuts but they kind
of stay the course for the rest of the
season and they have their traditions
like they don't wear the names on the
back of players names on the back of the
jerseys until they make it to a bowl
game and and so they've got that history
and tradition and heritage that they
mostly have stuck to but they've used
the Shamrock Series games as a way to
cut loose a little bit it feels like
helmets that that's that's been the
latest craze and how shiny they are
certainly with Notre Dame's I was
watching that against Louisville I was
like man that is bright yeah you know
they've got that really good metallic
gold paint and of course there's a story
behind it they wanted they say that it
mimics the gold dome on campus and and
yes you do see that in college I
remember when I started writing about
uniforms pretty much every college team
had one helmet except for Washington
State which for some reason had a home
helmet and a road helmet and that was
seen as bizarre two whole helmets and
now almost every college team has
multiple helmets they swap out different
color face masks they change the decals
from week to week and so it's a
free-for-all out there and then you
compare that to the NFL where they have
stuck to this one shell rule for safety
reasons they say the NCAA doesn't agree
with them on this but the NFL insists
that players and teams stick to one
helmet shell per season and so a lot of
throwback sand and different things that
we used to see on the field in the NFL
we don't see anymore and that's why the
Buccaneers for example can't wear their
old orange creamsicle throw backs
because that would require a white
helmet and and they they're stuck with
their pewter helmets they didn't that
one shell rule they'd have to stick with
the pewter shell and so the NFL is a
little hamstrung this year and that's
why you know this is the NFL's hundredth
anniversary and you may remember back in
1994 the 75th anniversary they did all
kinds of throw backs they rolled out a
big throwback program it was in fact the
first throwbacks ever to appear in the
NFL and fans loved it and they're not
really doing that this year
because of the one shell rule they can't
do it worse you
ever any sport any sport maybe the
inaugural Tampa Bay Devil Rays uniforms
in the late 90s you know the one Wade
Boggs was wearing when he got his
3,000th hit with that rainbow gradation
that was pretty awful we were just
talking about helmets certainly the
Jacksonville Jaguars two-tone helmet
that they wore
you know with the gold with the one at
the front and and black in the back or
maybe the other way around she was like
that was definitely the worst helmet in
NFL history they got rid of that
thankfully there's certainly plenty of
contenders for the worst I usually try
to focus on what's best
Thank You Paul we appreciate your time
my pleasure Dan that's Paul Lucas Unni
watch.com columnist for Sports
Illustrated for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]